Ам Мосфельд - технологічний і промисловий район столиці Баварії Мюнхена.
Тут розмістилися
німецькі представництва таких транснаціональних
корпорацій як IBM і Panasonic.
Поруч зі світовими гігантами  розташований офіс
невеликої компанії Sevskiy GmbH.
Всі шестеро працівників цієї фірми приїхали з України,
четверо з них мають науковий ступінь доктора.
Засновник компанії Сергій Сєвський приїхав до Німеччини
у 1999-му році.
Тоді випускник Харківського технічного університету радіоелектроніки
отримав грант на наукові дослідження.
Захистив докторську. Працював інженером у Siemens Mobile.
Однак втратив роботу, коли збитковий підрозділ концерну
був проданий і остаточно збанкрутував.
Агенція з працевлаштування запросила Сергія на курси,
де він настільки вразив своїм пробним бізнес-планом, що йому одразу
дали під нього грант на заснування своєї фірми.
Інженер придбав обладнання і почав розробляти антени
та прилади високих частот. За вісім років існування
компанії Сергій взяв на роботу п"ятьох українців
і нині веде переговори з новими кандидатами.
Чому саме українці - тому що,
з одного боку, їм дуже важко
знайти роботу за кордоном,
наприклад у Німеччині,
адже німецьким підприємствам
не відомий рівень освіти,
рівень підготовки фахівців з України.
Сергій переконаний, що в Україні вдалося зберегти
сильну математичну, технічну і фізичну школи.
Однак в українських інститутах не навчають,
як заробляти на своїх знаннях.
Тоді як у Німеччині ще під час навчання аспіранти виконують замовлення
промислових підприємств.
Підприємець з України бере на роботу земляків, які вже відбулися в науці,
і разом з ними комерціалізує набуті знання,
розробляючи антени для "Інтернету речей".
Інтернет речей - це коли
звичайні речі, побутові прилади
"спілкуються" один з одним
і людина може управляти цими речами.
Для цього потрібні такі радіоелектронні модулі.
У лабораторії радіоінженер Юрій Овсяник під мікроскопом
перевіряє якість друкованих плат.
Юрій з Києва. Працює у фірмі лише місяць.
Оголошення про цю роботу знайшов в інтернеті.
Ось так виглядає вай-фай-антена під мікроскопом.
"Інтернет речей" стрімко розвивається, й інженери жартують,
що незабаром ставитимуть вай-фай навіть у домашні капці.
Власник компанії зізнається, що українці йому ментально ближчі
і працюється з ними легше, однак поки
він не готовий перенести свій бізнес в Україну.
Науковцю простіше запросити земляків на роботу в Німеччину.
Більшість українців, яких я знаю,
хотіли б жити і працювати в Україні.
І, звичайно, я би міг
заснувати таку фірму і в Україні,
але для цього потрібна допомога держави.
За словами бізнесмена, німецька держава видає гранти
не тільки на наукові дослідження або заснування фірми,
але й заохочує співпрацю між різними підприємствами,
залучаючи маленькі компанії зі специфічною
сферою діяльності до великих проектів.
Сергій Сєвський переконаний, що колись так буде і в Україні,
і тоді український високотехнологічний бізнес
з-за кордону повернеться в країну.